I don't know what this means what I feel
tough to right now for its way chuffed
you just got chopped like what I think
it means you're feeling like cocky or
like boastful I'm so chuffed about
tomorrow I'm so excited for tomorrow not
good
it's crazy to me how this is still
English this probably sounds so much
cooler with the accident
sleepy cuz I want a nap
cuz I'm mad good cuppa
it's a cop like a cup of tea chinwag but
like an end here but like chin Wang if
you go like is that a chin wag it's not
Wang it swagger chin wag I invited my
friends out for a chin wag to talk [ __ ]
[Music]
skint bloody skin a tee at the enemies
it sound like you're like turned pool is
skin & Conquer out with his mates de
niro naked my wife thought it said legit
at first but there's a space accelerate
car or it could just mean I'm gonna walk
there
oh that sounds correct run Tulsa talking
do you have a salad
what is nice it's like a douche bag like
you're a tosser nicht oh this sounds
familiar
isn't that like when you're saving he
nicked my bag at the Pope last night dog
stole swiped attached at MacArthur
nicked my pieced I'm pretty familiar
they're pissing me off
right is this like a trick question
this means you're wasted drunk I think
it's so cool because it's like the same
language but so many different things I
can come out of it I'm really bad at
pronouncing wires I don't